[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition lors du 7-8 journal sur tv 78 et
les titres de ce mercredi 31 janvier
c'est une tradition et même dans les
tous derniers jours de janvier la
cérémonie des voeux de saint quentin en
yvelines se tenait hier au vélodrome
nationale devant près de 2000 personnes
le président jean michel fourgous a
parlé des grands événements elle mais
aussi des anges du territoire en 2018
entretien le projet est lancé depuis la
mi-janvier à villepreux les enfants des
accueils de loisirs de la commune sont
sensibilisés au handicap jusqu'au 7 mars
ateliers échanges sont au programme pour
faire bouger les regards notre invité
est à l'origine de l'initiative ludovic
brio et directeur de l'accueil de
loisirs jacques gillet à villepreux et
puis troisième volet de notre dossier de
la rédaction consacrée à la culture
urbaine dans les yvelines cet art est né
dans la rue le parcours démocratisé par
les yamakasi à sa section aux
clayes-sous-bois le club de tumbling
propose des sessions pour répéter les
figures en toute sécurité
après la décrue une lente décrue dans
les yvelines toujours à placer ce soir
en vigilance orange inondations le pic a
été atteint sur le tronçon boucles de
seine en aval de conflans sainte
honorine et les inondations ils sont
plus forte par rapport à l'épisode de
2016 vingt-huit communes les actifs leur
plan communal de sauvegarde sur les
secteurs des ponts du pecq de fin d'oise
et de poissy est la circulation reste
très difficile je rappelle également que
le trafic du rer c est interrompue à
paris et aux gares de versailles
chantiers sans cire et saint quentin en
yvelines jusqu'au lundi 5 février au
moins 50 ans en yvelines qui aura
attendu à la toute fin du mois de
janvier pour présenter à ses voeux pour
2010 8 cérémonie de l'agglomération hier
au vélodrome nationale à montigny le
bretonneux
près de 2000 personnes étaient présentes
pour l'occasion une soirée qui a débuté
en musique puis s'est poursuivie à vélo
avant de se terminer par le discours de
jean michel fourgous
une première pour le président de la
collectivité élu en octobre
il a présenté les événements et défis
année pour saint quentin en yvelines
nous l'avons interrogé après la
cérémonie elle les images sont signés
camille lambert 30 janvier cérémonie de
voeux de 50 ans neeve édition vélodrome
nationale à montigny le bretonneux
bonsoir jean michel fourgous le
président les républicains de saint
quentin en yvelines élu en octobre
je le rappelle il ya la cérémonie de
voeux c'est bien sûr l'occasion de
rappeler ce qui s'est passé en 2017
c'est aussi le moment d'annoncer ce qui
va arriver en 2018 les grands projets du
territoire
forcément 2018 à 50 ans yves hinse et
c'est l'année de la ryder cup
quatre cent mille spectateurs qui vont
venir sur cet événement à 50 ans divine
troisième événement le plus médiatique
au monde
on est à huit mois de l'événement
comment comment l'agglomération se
prépare à se prépare-t-elle à recevoir
cet événement bien et une mobilisation
générale de tous nos services
mais il ya aussi déjà une organisation
propre l'organisation l'ingénieur cup
heureusement mais ça nous demande bien
sûr vous pouvez énergie et de mettre des
moyens ce qui participe aussi
puis derrière bien entendu c'est aussi
entraînement pour que le golf national
on s'entraîne bien pour les jeux
olympiques aussi on va l'utiliser donc
c'est pour nous une sorte de 6,2
ça serait de répétition générale pour
penser j'ai eu ma clique qui vont
arriver en 2024
mais on a plus gros événement bien sûr
on a et puis on a aussi tout ce qui est
économique ici on est très contents de
voir les événements sportifs fossiles et
des équipements aussi prestigieux qui
nous ont permis d'ailleurs certainement
en avoir aussi les jeux olympiques
donc le bien sûr le l'état d'esprit est
très la gagne ici avec des très belles
voix lui dit
on a les meilleurs ingénieurs les
meilleurs rebelles et les entreprises et
bien
on a une université
il va certainement prendre la première
place française
là on à paris saclay quête d'un des plus
beaux rassemblements de cerveaux
français pour pour demain sortir les
brevets
aussi la richesse de la france la
réussite entrepreneuriale française
ici ça respire le l'esprit
entrepreneurial et on est content
d'avoir deux événements sportifs bien
sûr brillant comme soient organisées
alors il ya un dossier épineux aussi qui
va arriver et qui est sûre cette année
2018 c'est bien sur cette ligne 18 alors
la ligne 18 50 ans de l'aveu est l'aveu
ce dès 2024
elle espère la voir à dès 2024 retrait
c'est juste le projet pour le moment
arrivé en 2024 sur le plateau de saclay
l'arrivée à saint quentin en yvelines et
à versailles est prévue elle pour 2030
la mise de transport et les spet les
avait deux bornes pardon a annoncé
récemment face aux sénateurs que le
calendrier la ligne 18 elle est très
difficile à tenir pourquoi 50 en il doit
avoir cette ligne est pourquoi il est
important que les délais soient
respectés
bien sûr qu'un pays qu un tel déficit
le dîner à près de 100 milliards on
ignore ce qui est vrai ce n'est pas vrai
en plus qui promet
pour les prochaines municipales pour
gagner les prochaines municipales ils
ont divagué on va remettre la promesse
qu'on n'a pas tenu longtemps raismois la
remettre aux municipales joue sur les
municipales donc ont manipulé les gens
enfin ça c'est insupportable
bon on sait très bien que l'état n'a pas
les moyens
trouve pas de milliards pour pousser
line is 8 ici avec derrière le projet
paris saclay qui est un des plus gros
producteurs d'oeufs et accélérateur de
croissance et d'emplois marchands et de
savoir-faire de haute valeur ajoutée
enfin ils n'ont pas les moyens de
trouver ces deux milliards comment
est-ce qu'ils vont promettre demain 22
milliards 1 faut être sérieux c'est pas
sérieux de dire ça d'ailleurs
maintenant ils ont d'autres notre
qualité moi je veux pas
montre aux français ils ont cinq ans
pour le faire là les arbitrages vont
être reçus très prochainement pouvait
l'info dans 50 ans divise cette ligne 18
pourquoi il tenait tant parce que vous
avez d'abord la plus belle université
vous en donne construire paris-saclay
vous avez 7 cet espace extraordinaire de
rassemblement d'accélérateur de
croissance d'intelligence qui va être le
haut-lieu de l'intelligence artificielle
en fait parler sa classe
il vous avait plein de projets autour
mais sur deux 52 de versailles à saint
quentin à saclay permettre de définir de
préparer de faire venir les meilleurs
écoles enfin vous avez toutes les plus
belles écoles encore normale sup science
qui n'arrivait enfin on n'est pas
content de rassembler tous nous faire
venir les plus belles entreprises et
leur dire bah non vous trouve pas les
transports ne sont pas sérieux l'état
doit être fiable je veux dire on ne peut
pas vouloir avoir une image d'autorité
les voir après imposer des décisions
revenir contre leur avis et bien pas
être capable de tenir compte de tenir
leurs engagements
l'état aujourd'hui la foire peut-être
redéfinir son rôle redéfinir bien sûr
son périmètre aussi on ne peut pas
continuer à avoir un état qui perd près
de 5 milliards par an c'est pas possible
dernière chose ce sera ma dernière
question
vous êtes très attaché au développement
économique les chiffres ont été rendu
officiel là cette semaine
1,9 pour cent de croissance l'an passé
en france croissance économique c'est du
jamais vu depuis 2011 est ce que ce
territoire saint quentin en yvelines
voilà est-ce qu'il est acteur de cette
croissance on rappelle un 16 mille
entreprises qui sont sur le territoire
est ce qu'on la ressent aussi ici à
saint quentin en yvelines
cette croissance 50 ans est le deuxième
pays b
en france par habitant
on est un accélérateur de croissance ont
eu une plateforme d'hypercroissance dont
convenait bien à ce sujet c'est bon ça
il faut nous laisser travailler parce
que avec d'autres d'ailleurs mais on
tire d'autres partenaires mais faut
laisser ce qui marche
vous savez faut pousser les gens qui
montent faut pas lâcher élan qui tombe
non plus et les tailles la son cursus au
milieu et il doit pas lâcher les gens
qui montrent que nous mais en fait on
alimente tout le monde
derrière et autour on attire les offres
d'aidé des sites et expérimentés ne
viendrait pas en france il avait pas cet
environnement donc voilà on est tous
presse métro inc à la fin elle tout le
monde a pu réussir ce pays qui a deux
les potentiels hors norme sous le pays
la france regorge de talents mais
laissons les travailler s'exprimer
donnons leur des responsabilités pas
seulement les mecs qui parlent bien
moins la classe parlante elle commence à
m'agacer
moi j'aime bien la classe la classe qui
qui créent vous savez comme on est
souvent à 51,10 bielecki cause et les
qu'ils font moi je préfère les qu'ils
font
posé on peut causer de temps en temps
mais et
voilà la france elle s'est pas fait
qu'avec de la rhétorique donc un moment
donné ou avec des jeux de communication
avec des manipulations là on aimerait
avoir un peu plus de sincérité de
sérieux de compétences de résultats
réels et là je vous promets on
retrouvera un climat de confiance pas
refaire tout le monde a compris le
message merci jean michel soit vous
arrêtez avec tout président est l'heure
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ici au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines où se tenait ce mardi 30
janvier à la cérémonie des voeux de
l'agglomération et justement nous
l'évoquions dans l'interview 2018 sera
marquée à saint quentin en yvelines par
la ryder cup à 8 mois de cet événement
la fédération française de golf
présentait ce matin ses voeux le sujet
principal bien sûr cette coupe du monde
de golf mais aussi l'open de france qui
se tiendra en juillet deux événements
qui se tiendront donc organisé sur elle
et green saint quentinois mickaël
landreau et quentin le frère 2018 année
charnière pour le golf français le
président de la ffg l'a répété pendant
ses voeux à la presse ce mercredi 31
janvier dans huit mois la ryder cup sera
organisé pour la toute première fois en
france sur le parcours du golf national
à saint quentin en yvelines
des équipes travaillent sur ce dossier
depuis la désignation officielle en 2011
travail de longue haleine chaque étape a
été balisé à réaliser les
investissements et le budget financier
méprise et donc nous serons gros oui
parce que c'est l'épreuve la plus grande
dans le monde
qu'est-ce qu'on peut atteindre jusqu'à
un milliard de téléspectateurs ce qui
n'est pas rien donc oui on joue gros
dans ce sens là le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
également fin juin sur le parcours de
l'albatros la 102e édition de l'open de
france de golf depuis l'année dernière
l'événement intégrer les rolex séries a
vu sa dotation passer de trois à sept
millions de dollars trois mois avant la
ryder cup la compétition devrait attirer
des têtes d'affiché nous aurons une
édition 2010 8 d'anthologie avec chef
faire de nouveaux venus du continent
américain et les meilleurs joueurs
romont pour venir tester ce parcours new
look avant d'accueillir cet homme la
halde après cette année 2018 chargé la
fédération française de golf espère
booster le nombre de licenciés dans ces
678 club pour la saison prochaine
ils sont près de 400 14000 golfeurs
inscrits cette année santé un nouveau
site pour les personnes âgées à
versailles l'établissement lépine a été
inaugurée lundi dernier une plate forme
de services gérontologique de 112 lits
c'est le fruit d'une collaboration
public-privé une première en france
les détails avec ce sujet de marylène
iapichino patrick jacques de dixmude et
quentin le frère
le projet date de 2011
un établissement qui répond à une
demande grandissante versailles compte
en tout cinq ehpad son territoire les
plus de 75 ans représentent 10% de la
population
l'idée plutôt que de moderniser un
établissement vétuste créer un nouveau
projet dans une dynamique de
collaboration entre acteurs du soin aux
personnes âgées
on retrouve fait la réunification de 2
et pat deux établissements qui étaient
distincts dans des bâtiments distincts
et on a rapatrié également le service de
soins infirmiers à domicile qui était
derrière la mairie auparavant
l'initiative est une première en france
la ville s'est associée à entreprendre
pour humaniser la dépendance une
structure membre de l'association
habitat et humanisme
ensemble ils ont lancé une société
coopérative d'intérêt collectif
un partenariat public privé dans le
secteur du sanitaire et sociale pour
lever 1 million d'euros de fonds la
population a pu prendre part au projet
est réalisé un investissement solidaire
et fiscalement intéressants on travaille
sur une approche
à partir de laquelle chacun sent qu'en
fait ce qu'il est content pour le
résultat qui est recherché c'est à dire
finalement le soin et le prendre soin
des personnes qui sont accueillis lépine
versailles intervient sur trois pôles
différents un service de soins
infirmiers à domicile dont une partie de
l'équipe et spécialisée alzheimer un
accueil de jour avec des activités
adaptées et une partie hébergement avec
112 lits occupés par des résidents
depuis décembre dernier
c'est une opération qui a débuté depuis
le 17 janvier à villepreux le partage de
l'espoir sensibilise les enfants de 3 à
11 ans des accueils de loisirs de la
commune il sensibilise au handicap
cette opération c'est jusqu'au 7 mars
avec moi en plateau pour en parler
ludovic brio bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le directeur de l'accueil de loisirs
jacques gillet à villepreux vous êtes à
l'origine de cette initiative partage de
l'espoir on va parler bien sûr du
programme dans un instant l'envié déjà
d'organiser cet événement elle est
partie d'un constat ludovic brio c'est
que vous avez constaté outre les enfants
ont un vendeur de la différence voilà
non pas de la différence ce qui ce qui
amène du coût et du rejet ou de la
moquerie et le but
l'objectif principal de cette
sensibilisation c'est de sensibiliser
vraiment les enfants aux différents
handicaps de façon à qu'ils se rendent
compte qu est ce que le handicap avant
de juger trop rapidement par exemple
comme le stéréotype cette expérience que
voilà il pense que le handicap si ce
n'est que son camp fait qu'en fauteuil
roulant d'accord alors qu'il ya beaucoup
de rêves à un domaine très vaste
plusieurs plusieurs handicaps
je n'ai donc l'idée os et de peut-être
aussi changer leur regard
il skie par une paire une perception
négative du handicap
également ils peuvent avoir une
perception négative mais sait d'où vient
la sensibilisation c'est qu'ils aient un
regard positif
oui voilà qui vraiment que
qu'ils veuillent pas que tant de
différences que ça que ça c'est que ce
sont aussi des êtres humains et que mon
échec de mener tous différents donc
voilà c'est le but c'est de la 106 alors
comment s'est mis en place cette
opération comment a germé l'idée en tête
quelle préparation finalement aussi
avant cette cette opération partage de
l'espoir donc le départ tout d'être tout
d'abord c'est ça fait très longtemps que
je souhaiterais mettre que je souhaitais
mettre un projet de sensibilisation un
handicap dans les accueils de loisirs
d'accord et du coup j'ai fait une
formation l'année passée j'en ai causé à
ma chef de service qui était partante
pour le projet du coup j'ai réuni cinq
animateurs donc un animateur pas
structure très bien que pour que plus
les activités puissent tourner dans
chaque structure mais aussi faire
intervenir des intervenants pour comme
le langage des signes par exemple où
nous ne sommes nous n'est pas n'est pas
formé lsf mais que les intervenants sont
formés donc pour les enfants c'est
vraiment plus intérêt à les selfs langue
des signes française c'est ça oui donc
les lits des oueds de pouvoir aussi
faire intervenir des spécialistes sur
sur la question vous avez dit vous avez
suit une formation c'est une quel type
de formation c'était une formation par
la ddcs des yvelines et donc qui m'avait
beaucoup parlé parce que du coup on dit
pas des enfants handicapés en 10 des
enfants extraordinaires et non pas moins
handicapés et pour nous ce sont des
enfants ordinaires
la finalité dans cette opération c'est
de faire changer les regards des emplois
là si on peut faire changer le regarde
pas pour aux enfants et que les enfants
apportent le message aux parents ça
serait ça serait formidable
plusieurs objectifs donc sensibiliser
informer les enfants faire évoluer les
les regards vous le faites par le biais
d'actions ces sacs avec quelles
sont-elles ces actions vous avez donc le
mes animateurs préparent ont préparé des
activités aussi bien sur un parcours à
la veille des parcours de motricité en
situation de handicap ou sap et avec un
bras en moins une jambe en moi il y à
des quizz sur l'accessibilité
donc on va se promener on dit là est-ce
que s'adapter pour une personne
handicapé quoi d'accord d'ailleurs on le
voit sur ces images on a filmé
aujourd'hui un parcours à l'aveuglé
ça c'était à l'accueil de loisirs du val
joyeux à villepreux là l'idée de ce
parcours par exemple c'est les mettre en
condition vraiment de non voyants
donc ils ont un masque sur les yeux avec
un avec un bâton et doit se déplacer
avec des obstacles de façon qu'ils aient
l'impression de que voilà ce que ressent
aussi les personnes non voyantes et
cette journée d'aujourd'hui de mercredi
a été particulièrement riche en atelier
plusieurs animations est aussi un quiz
sur l'accessibilité à l'accueil de
loisirs gérard philipe au clos cruise
at-il eu un parcours de motricité
toujours pour les mater cette fois ci
pour
en situation d'handicap comme je disais
à mon rein en moins ou une jambe en moi
et nous sommes partis avec huit enfants
à l'iufm de bailly donc pour un échange
avec des enfants de l'institut qu'elle
16 en plus de ces ateliers finalement il
ya un échange aussi qui est créé en tout
les enfants et ses enfants
extraordinaires comme vous le dites ces
enfants qui sont atteints d'un handicap
alors hier un temps fort pour ce partage
de l'espoir ça sera mercredi prochain 7
février il y aura une grande journée
organisée à l'accueil de loisirs gérard
philipe toujours à villepreux donc avec
l'institut d'éducation motrice de ben
ali est également l'association
handisport tout à fait et on va mettre
en place un basket en fauteuil roulant à
l'atelier poterie mais adapté aussi bien
pour les enfants de l'iem que pour les
nôtres oui et on va faire une belle
fresque souvenir de notre échange qui
d'ailleurs on souhaiterait avec dilemme
poursuivre du coup notre partenariat des
changes
vraiment tout au long de l'année on
constatera pas pour le 7 mars par ibm
mais on continuera tout au long de
l'année au moins une fois par mois que
de se rencontrer
la force de l'opération s'est finalement
si ce trail de partenariat avec lil
wayne avec aussi les associations c'est
ça il a été mis en place
qu'est ce que vous espérez on l'a dit
alors faire changer les regards mais
qu'est ce qui ferait finalement que
cette opération à vos yeux soit une
réussite
le taux de participation des enfants oui
donc qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce qu'ils
disent les enfants quel est le ressenti
bava
ma grande surprise c'est que les enfants
sont demandeurs de du coût de la
sensibilisation
donc je vois le soir même en accueil du
soir c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait sur le
handicap
oui aujourd'hui sur quel thème on va
travailler donc du coup on fait des
débats ont fait et ça les captifs quoi
et on imagine une sensibilisation utile
aussi parce qu'ils vont peut-être en
parler à leurs parents à leurs familles
peut-être à leur futur enfant aussi
c'est une trace aussi sur l'avenir que
voulez vous les tracés justement ben oui
c'est s'ouvrir aux autres
voilà c'est une ouverture sur les autres
on est tous différent donc il est
important de respecter
qu'on soit une jambe en moins un bras en
moins pas en fauteuil roulant non
voyants sourds
enfin voilà on est tous là pour se
respecter mutuellement donc je trouve ça
important mais ça doit passer un message
voilà de de savoir-vivre de respect
l'opération je le précise aller jusqu'au
7 mars à à villepreux merci ludovic
briochine avec nous à l'origine donc de
ce partage de l'espoir et je rappelle
également que vous êtes le directeur de
l'accueil de loisirs j'ai perdu non la
grève des défis jacques gillet et c'est
toujours à villepreux merci d'avoir été
avec nous suite de notre dossier de la
semaine consacrée à la culture urbaine
dans les yvelines cette discipline est
née dans la rue le parcours consiste à
franchir des obstacles urbains et
naturels en réalisant des figures
acrobatiques et aux clayes-sous-bois le
club de tumbling propose des sessions et
des sessions pardon en gymnase pour
s'entraîner et répéter les mouvements
toute sécurité reportage de michael et
demi d'euros
[Musique]
souvenez vous c'était en 2001 les
français découvrent les yamakasi des
acrobates de rue qui défilent et gravité
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les figures pratiqué dans le
film ce sont transposés dans la vie
réelle aux clayes-sous-bois une section
parcours a vu le jour en 2011 pour
répondre à la demande
ici la pratique de ce sport urbain
rebaptisé fristel gym se passe en
intérieur dans un gymnase une chute pour
vous est fatal quand même parce que vous
maîtrisez pas 100% de la figure je leur
ai proposé d'apprendre en toute sécurité
des figures acrobatiques et dès lors que
la figure est acquise en intérieur
maintenant on peut le faire l'extérieur
il y aura un goût beaucoup moins
d'accidents depuis la création de cette
section la pratique de cette discipline
connaît un franc succès au club
le nombre de licenciés est passé de cinq
adhérents la première année à une
quarantaine de pratiquants venus de
toutes les yvelines pour cette saison
2010 8
c'est notre corps c'est pas un vélo
c'est pas en équipement c'est vraiment
notre corps c'est une option chutes sont
faute score si on doit être très
rigoureux on est très libre on apprend
vraiment de au fond n'est capable une
grosse apprennent à lire quand on lance
la figure il ya une montée d'adrénaline
et dès qu'on la rentrée on
en 100 euros une fois les bases maîtrisé
pendant ses cours de trois heures le
vendredi ses têtes brûlées dépasse les
frontières du gymnase gimme pour
pratiquer ce sport dans son lieu de
naissance la rue les pratiquants peu les
traceurs utilise le milieu urbain et la
nature pour réaliser des figures
[Musique]
on n'est pas vraiment des mechas quiz
pour ça que les gens partent en ont peur
dans la rue c'est il pense qu'on se
lance comme ça et que si on se rate
notre année on passe beaucoup de temps
on sait on sait de quoi on est capable
on fait quand même beaucoup de repérage
avril sa lancée et c'est une phase très
importante parce que sinon
la peur prend le dessus et lancement en
danger alors qu'on aurait peut-être été
capable de le faire son sac on fait très
attention avant de se lancer pour
l'emporter mouvement smc des
clayes-sous-bois espère désormais
atteindre une centaine d'adhérents dans
les prochaines années la structure
pourrait surfer sur la dynamique de ce
sport qui vient d'être inscrite
officiellement dans la fédération
française de gymnastique
avant de se quitter l'école de musique
et de danse de trap organisé samedi son
tempo d'hiver c'est un rendez vous
annuel pour présenter l ensemble des
disciplines de l'établissement de plus
de 500 élèves il y a trois départements
la danse la musique classique et les
musiques actuelles principe original du
tempo divers les spectateurs ont pris
part un parcours à travers l'école
auditorium salle d'orchestre et hall
d'entrée pour découvrir c'est trois
pôles propos recueillis par nicolas
d'andrews chacun reste dans sa maison on
a vraiment la danse d'un côté la musique
classique de l'autre et les musiques
actuelles qui termine donc ce parcours
donc c'est vraiment un choix d'avoir
pour cette cette soirée-là trois
identités différentes qui forment
finalement l'identité global de l'école
ce journal qui n'est pas terminée encore
avec de la culture 50 voix pour un
hommage et didier gustin revient avec un
nouveau spectacle dans as tu verras
claude nougaro rené à travers différents
chanteurs de la scène française didier
gustin était sur la scène de montigny le
bretonneux hier soir mélanie poker a
assisté à la représentation
[Musique]
joey starr chante claude nougaro le
mashup est signée didier gustin
l'homme aux cent voire en hommage à
l'artiste dont il est fan ça faisait
partie des premiers chanteurs que
génitales et c'est aussi le premier
chanteur qui est venu on voir sur scène
en 1987 au théâtre du tourtour et il m'a
dit que justin tu as trouvé quelque
chose maintenant il te faut creuser
et puis un jour j'ai fait un rêve j'ai
rêvé d'un spectacle qui s'appellerait as
tu verras avec des musiciens avec et
puis la musique quelle bonne idée
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un qui est vraiment
écrivait vraiment très très bien et même
le soir maintenant quand je joue je
redécouvre encore ses textes et la
qualité de ses textes et la profondeur
parce que vous y tient mais ça il
voulait parler de sa chimie est bien sûr
voilà on m'a dit que je redécouvre les
textes elle soit avec as tu verras
didier gustin entraîne dans la maison
jadis habité par claude nougaro 50
invités viennent chercher l'inspiration
d'une mystérieuse font-elles johnny
hallyday eddy mitchell ou encore raphaël
interprète les grands titres de
l'artiste toulousain
m
j'ai voulu choisir les chansons les plus
connues les plus emblématiques
emblématique fut aussi celle que
j'aimais et après on est après j'ai pris
les interprètes pour qui calais avec
dont quatre boules de cuir quelqu'un qui
se bat qui est costaud j'ai mis johnny
bidonvilles bas lavilliers renault il
faut tourner la page parce qu'il a quand
même tourné une page puisqu'il est
revenu sur scène disparu depuis bientôt
14 ans claude nougaro laisse en héritage
didier gustin l'avait amené avec lui à
montigny le bretonneux
[Musique]
à toulouse
e
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal j'en
profite pour souhaiter une bonne route à
notre désormais que ce journaliste léa
rêve qui s'envole pour de nouvelles
aventures cette édition vous pouvez bien
sûr la retrouver en replay sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]